okay G cannon you got it why you gotta
play against Ryu Oh who's gonna be doing
the kicking let's see let's see
wow what a clever line what a corny line
to start huh here we go
all right let's fire this one up my
opponent is typing hi and that they have
the stream muted that is wonderful that
is perfect all right
they'd f6 and what Kings Indian know I
like whenever I see this I'm I almost
always just played d5 because I want to
turn into a queen pawn opening because
this guy doesn't like to be obstructed
in those situations so this is a very I
don't think I'll have any problems now
with my development this is a heading
towards a very quiet opening which is
right up my alley which is exactly what
I would like to see certainly my style
compared to tactical sharp variations
does anybody know why that's the case I
don't know if I've shared that I don't
know if I should share that should I
share that okay let's get my knight
do I want to break the pin let me just
break the pin I was thinking about
Knight B to d7 but I think I want to go
with c5 knight c6 so this is where he
belongs and it's Castle
I'm a lazy calculator so I don't like
sharp positions I don't want to have to
do some number crunching just take that
we just had with that exchange my bad
bishop for my opponents good bishop and
is it really necessary to keep the Queen
out of b5 is c5 as played as the Queen
gonna be annoying hitting at both c5 and
b7 I'm gonna do it I'm fine with that
now c5 I'm more a long time seeing that
this guy could turn out to be a problem
soon enough we'll have a rut being
thrown on the C file so these are gonna
this is a these two moves the c5 knight
c6 they certainly go hand-in-hand you
just take that guy my bishop is
unprotected but there aren't really any
tactics let's gentlemen Knight it out
here my bishop gets hit okay there's I'm
gonna a break the pin and now with that
last move there's both c3 and c4 that I
can look forward to maybe landing a
piece on if you could imagine the dark
scrub issues being exchanged and a rook
maybe sinking itself in on that c3
square
I don't know that b4 is a move that
could really be recommended so what I
might look to do now is or even get it
get a knight right there to c4 somehow
boom boom boom welcome a dark square
bishop exchange as soon as I move my
knight there's tension between these
guys the bishops so I do i do rook c8 or
do I prevent something like Knight a 4
because this night I'm pretty sure when
you make that rook move White's getting
ready to move the knight and then just
push this the only white pond that is
really I think considered a liability on
the white end
I do b5 and just clamp down on this
square I think I actually like that I
don't even want to give this night
it's not about clamping down on this
square right away because like I could
have done that a move later but it's
this move is coming with the time
constraint if I don't do b5 right away
the knight can make use of a4 yes I
could still get in b4 but now I have to
contend with the knight on c5 and I
don't really want to do that so this is
not an inconvenience this move defending
the knight and now I could pin poor I
could jump into this square and maybe I
should have looked into that first
instead of the rook move but I like this
better
attack that Queen there might be some
tricky stuff with 94 if the Queen goes
to this square there's gonna be a
problem though this is this position
reminds me of the black side of the
Catalan where black is trying to get in
a c5 advance but now it's the
corresponding square C for whites trying
to get in then I'm in the catalan and
the black side blacks trying to get in
c5 and in this position white would
really love to get this in but that is a
very long way off Knight c4 would also
come with tempo 94 trades a bunch
actually boat both Knight moves either
c4 or e for threatening a fork I'm just
gonna go with Knight here right away
I do h6 if the bishop goes here then
doing this is purposeful but after h6
Bishop here my Knight is hit I'm just
gonna go here right away I was
considering h6 to try and get a little
bit more out of the tension between
these bishops before placing my knight
in the center the reason why I would
want to do h6 is just for flight square
for my King more long-term seeing how we
do have all heavy pieces remaining all
major pieces
and now this is going to be a problem I
think now now white is having to deal
with a night I really want to land a
night there he's not going to be denied
that square also if there's one
particular pawn break my opponent could
maybe get in it's a four I'm just going
to rule that out right away a night on
the grim in this case is not so grim
actually maybe I shouldn't have done
that
okay this is the other pawn break that
we might be seeing so positional
positional positional the other thing
about this night being on a four is that
if there's one square that I really
don't want my opponent to be getting to
with the night its c5 so let's jump here
this is stopping this break this is
sniffing out any possibility of a night
landing on c5 and sitting there for any
amount of time my other night could sink
in here how do I make further progress
Queen b6 seems all the more appealing
not only because opposite the king but
oh hang on just take with my queen does
it really matter
yeah I'm gonna take with my Bishop I
don't okay now okay I'm gonna play here
this is weakened what I was gonna say is
this is appealing because it's opposite
the king and also because that F pawn
moved this is just a more weakened point
so I think I have a very clear plan
right now and that is to just pile up on
that c3 pawn but to be honest I want my
bishop in a better location first and I
think this is a good spot press around
the night time to double up maybe I
should have just jumped right in here my
opponent is moving very quick flight
Square from my King there is no rush
here it's expand over here I might want
to clamp down on this structure and I
have just that okay and now I'm gonna
transfer my attention bump my king up
and I can play on both sides of the
board now I can use my
better flexibility I guess with
pinpointing the weakest link I think the
weakest link is now h3 I mean this guy
is pretty weak on c3 but I'm gonna I'm
gonna target h3 I think white was maybe
acting too quickly with those pawn
advances and one little slip-up can
really now present yourself with a new
target and h3 is it ok now that's
dropping the pun that's what I was
talking about earlier about my knight on
a for watching over for c5 if that move
didn't come about I was thinking about
rerouting my knight here now I could
take like this this is a pin can't have
pawn takes has to go like this or with
the Queen I could pick up another pawn
this is weak these guys are both
weakened that pond is now hit twice and
I'm gonna come back to d6 to hit this
pawn and I can start pushing my a pond
as well okay this is definitely
crumbling now there is most likely no
good defense here I'm just gonna come
back have my queen guard everything on
this side of the board stop any dark
square checks Queen ending this is a
passed pawn get rolling I just want to
make sure that there are no discovered
tricks I have possibilities for
discovered check against their King and
they might have it to with being
opposite my queen even with the time
this pawn is very fast maybe I shouldn't
have given up that pond but okay they
didn't take on 85 keep pushing my queen
wants to be on c2 even if I have to give
up a pond just to get the Queen's off
that's quite all right
for example here next if the King played
to d2 I probably still play here King
and pawn endgame is winning there are no
possibilities as far as I'm seeing for a
perpetual check and now my king could
sneak in ah they didn't go after that
pawn okay they resigned
good game G cannon let's back up I'm
gonna flip that board and look at things
from your perspective my opponent is
saying thank you for the game you are
welcome so my first suggestion is and I
had this I think I'm the last stream I
did I was talking about how you really
shouldn't obstruct your sea pawns with
your Knights if it's a queen pond
opening and then somebody came back and
said well there's a you can do that in
the black mare Deemer and that's true
like in this position right here you
could do with something with the e4
takes followed up with f3 but if you're
not gonna run forward that I would
really discourage going with Knight c3
here Queen pond like opening sea pond
wants to do one of two things
a defend your own center or B strike at
my center and he didn't have that
ability for really the whole game this
turned out to be your first weakness and
then there were other ones later that
came about with that H pawn but this is
the main thing piece placement the other
thing that you can maybe try for before
I even get in before I even get in c5
when I'm doing this a six move which is
not a developing move it's strictly
preventative keeping pieces out of b5
maybe you can be looking into this efore
advance press forward in the center and
I'll probably be giving up the center
because I don't know if I'm really too
happy about or I don't know if I would
really want to allow this 'if I've
advanced gaining space so I think maybe
looking into e4 if you did efore right
here
efore i believe i tape takes takes
Knight takes there might be something a
little bit tricky because if I take the
bishop maybe you have Knight takes F and
you're on my queen I don't know I was I
was thinking about that I mean if you
really do want to get an e4 you could
always take out my knight and then push
maybe that's maybe that's not so bad
take my knight I recapture push forward
in the center
hmm and another thing I'm wondering is
since you have not yet committed your
king is it a possibility to maybe Castle
queenside and maybe get pushing your
Jeep on in H pond I don't know it's
interesting possibility haven't
committed your King so anyhow the
possibility for an e4 push and in short
that did not happen and now this becomes
very awkward your C pun definitely if a3
is made to keep out a piece from this
square and that alone okay maybe I could
see that but if you're doing a 483 to
get in before you have to shy away from
that these two squares are too weak and
now too difficult and this is you're
fighting a very very uphill battle
without a doubt that's that's the mean
that's the main point here it's just a
matter of me pouncing on these squares
and I don't know that I really gave you
a window of opportunity I don't know if
there's a way to really get out I did
have some slight fear at this point
about maybe a pawn push in the center
taking advantage maybe of my queen being
opposite your rook not so sure though
that that would work but once once that
came about yes you're shutting down my
bishop here about these squares are just
too much to overcome I would also
recommend on this side once we do get to
this point don't be too quick don't be
so quick to move this pawn in fact one
thing you should be considering is
stopping me from playing h4 to cramp
that clamp down on the H and G pawns so
if anything instead of a king move and
maybe it was a mouse slip but look into
g3 getting ready to meet h4 with g4 and
at least this side of the board is not
opening up you're strictly defensive
right here and these rooks are pretty
much without a move they can't there's
no like tempo moves that you could just
shuffle back and forth and still defend
c3 so maybe be a little bit more patient
but I believe we were pretty much in
bullet mode at that point weren't we
yeah that's that's the that's the last
thing really can't go with that a 3b
floor move and really as far back as the
earliest point in the game the idea of
Knights III don't obstruct that sea pump